Richard while I got you in here this
this music that you caught JD listening
to yeah
it's just his kind of music yeah he's
into this kind of stuff I was like I was
like why in the hell do you go to raves
do you do ecstasy he's like no I just
like to listen to it Richard walks by
JD's little booth you know JD spends
most of his day here so he's like
grooving to some music and this song is
this so this is the last kind of music
that I'd expect ID to listen to I cut it
down it was an hour-long song I could
have done like three minutes
[Music]
what kind of what kind of music is that
technology a sec no strays yeah see I I
got that without listening to it first
and I started playing in here didn't
what do you do to that you did wholly in
dynamite yeah you know I it's a lot like
this song Napoleon dancers too in that
final auditoriums the only time I listen
to music is on my iPhone on the train
when I come and you listen you got this
and you hadn't heard it before yeah you
bought it
[Music]
Richard's dancing with the devil
is that how you dance to it yeah a
little dance sorry I can't believe that
what does that lift your spirits
uh no you know that's like a little more
like poppier than what I like I like it
more like aggressive like I like it fast
like that but like more aggressive and
angrier I like Vanessa Brothers I like
Brooklyn bounce
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the girls face this type of thing in our
life Oh will you want to say something
just that I've seen that JT dance so he
definitely dances this music no I think
this subtle hand move no you see you've
seen me dance for like it's stupid like
I don't
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
we're gonna learn that dance Napoleon
Dynamite here's your homework for
tonight go I'm watching the Pauline
tournament and copy that African dance
he does I actually bought this oh really
why would you it was like like the
Grateful Dead I thought you have to be
on ecstasy to be into that but actually
what's that on your iPod GT has this on
his iPod with those [ __ ] iPods when
you're walking around on the street no
wonder you got mugged I would just watch
a TV show where they go up to people on
the street and play what's on their iPod
just to see what met you know like like
you'd see JD walking down the street you
figure he's listening like a you know a
chess instruction or something
this song is over an hour long how could
that be an hour is it really an hour
long it's like they they do like mixes
of different songs and they mix them
together never stop this mad Beach
[Music]
there might be the funniest opening ever
[Music]
that's gotta be whatever JD walks in the
studio
[Music]
we'll be like hey JD come in and tell us
what was on TV last night
[Music]
really no different an act of Hollywood
[Music]
Frank Annette be officially JD song it
certainly can't